Game of Thrones was welcomed back into
all of our lives on HBO last night
season seven premiered and it is on
every single Sunday bless it thank
goodness it's back it was way too long
of a wait 9:00 Eastern every single
Sunday on HBO and the gentleman who
plays Samwell Tarly is sitting right
here on the set John Bradley good to see
you sir good to see you it's Hayden I'm
great you are one I mean out of all the
characters on Game of Thrones um and we
had kid Harrington here last week who
plays John Snow and I think the two you
guys are the ones without any darkness
in their hearts of anybody that is
pretty much on the show would you agree
with that yeah no I think there's
definitely darkness there there's
darkness within all these characters you
know Sam for example is a character that
carries a lot of psychological scars
around well that's that's true get a
very kind of abusive childhood and he's
very psychologically damaged and it kind
of exists in a world that he can't cope
in but your heart does anytime he just
wants to do good yeah he's got a very
very pure heart and and you know it the
problem with Sam it if you're told that
you're a coward from the day you were
born you're going to start to believe it
but I think over the last couple of
things you've seen him stop believing
that he's starting to believe just how
worthwhile and brave and how courageous
he can be but it's just taking a while
to strip away all those layers of kind
of psychological baggage no there's
darkness with everybody in Game of
Thrones it's just how they choose or
choose not to let that affect their
heart and soul right but just in terms
of rooting for characters oh god yeah
I'd like to think so okay but with Game
of Thrones folks like you normally meet
a very untimely grisly ending well
that's that's the thing Sam's survived
this long against all odds
yes nobody would've thought that he
could have survived for this long
something out the wall I'm no look at it
well wall eats folks like Samwell Tarly
from for breakfast lunch and dinner
well the wall is a very very kind of
unforgiving place but the problem with
that is that the wall is actually a
safer place for Sam than his home was
because his father hated him so much
that his father was perfectly prepared
to kill him in order to get him out of
the
way so that the favored younger son will
have a quicker route to the seat of the
house but so Sam is the only person who
being shipped however many hundreds of
miles nor to be amidst cutthroat
criminals and murderers that's a much
safer environment for him and sitting
around a dinner table with his family
John Bradley replaced Samwell Tarly from
Game of Thrones here on the Rich Eisen
show and then you're trying to become a
maester yes okay now last year at the
end of Game of Thrones we saw you show
up at Old Town and you're in this
monster library right yeah
and you're trying to become a maester
and learn in all of this spot where the
academics one would think of all of
Westeros are coming in there that's
right and now we see you starting off
this season I'm not I don't think I'm
spoiling too much Brockman is it can we
go there yeah I think so can we go to
your first scene from from laughs yes
fine I mean I mean it that you're
cleaning out the latrines of maesters
right oh that what you're doing you're
clean you're literally cleaning up their
crime scene it was feeding them soup and
then to put it politely cleaning up the
aftermath of the soup
post so soup and then post soups even
possibly it kind of is kind of the cycle
of life where the hell did that come
from
oh is that part of trying to become
maesters well it's kind of the bottom
rung of the ladder
what would think and Sam thought that he
was going to go there and be immediately
immersed in books and and so fill his
role and fulfill his promise to Jon that
he's going to go there and fight the
same battle alongside Jon Snow we're
just gonna fight it with knowledge and
learning and education and academia
instead of with a sword and that's why
he appealed to Jon to send into the
Citadel that's why he's there but I
think Sam just imagined that he was a
slightly shorter process yeah actually I
was kind of it's kind of funny and kind
of memorable and wacky as that sequence
is I think that it serves a very very
important function in that in the course
of the season as well the fact that we
the first time we see Sam is extremely
disillusioned extremely kind of
disenchanted extremely fast rate
and he realizes that he's kind of being
sold a lie and I'm a blubbering sold a
lie but he's kind of invested in a lie
for so long he thought that the Citadel
was going to be this place of learning
and this place where he could ascend to
a higher kind of academic plane and he's
down there doing these disgusting menial
jobs and so it's like he's like it's
like finding you know Santa Claus
doesn't exist yeah or if he does exist
you're getting a dirty bedpan because
yeah post supercenters post soup and now
we had again kid Harrington last week he
did not he said that them the creators
are Weiss and Benioff yeah are sadistic
people and the question is is did they
actually put real actual stool stool in
your scene is this what you were
actually having to deal with in real
life no no they're not that sadistic god
bless them but I think what I actually
had to work with was one stage less
unpleasant than their but it here's a
tip and every day is a school day after
all if you if you want to create
we're going to pull out the research
with stool on the on screen apparently
wet fruitcake Oh wet fruitcake is the
way to do it and of course wet through
cake on the first take at 6:30 in the
morning is fine wet fruitcake
at 3:30 after a day under hot light
becomes slightly less than Pleasant them
still nine hours of wet fruitcake yes
essentially would use essentially what I
did and that was the same sequence to
shoot because we shot it in five-second
burst over the space of a couple of days
yes and so I just had to make sure that
I created those moments and trust the
director in the Edit and that and David
and Dan that they were going to kind of
stitch it together into this monster but
I I kind of had no real sense of the
kind of structure of it when I was
filming it's only when I saw it for the
first time last week that I realized oh
that's what they had Mia gearing that's
why I was doing all that stuff so that
week when everybody else everybody else
when I was shooting that on my own
everybody else was out here at the Emmys
[Laughter]
so maybe maybe that sadistic thing maybe
you have appointment oh man we're going
to be back in 60 seconds talk more Game
of Thrones it is as red-hot a show as
there's ever been in the mana play
Samwell Tarly John Bradley is here and
we'll talk a little bit of sports and
some more Game of Thrones I try to get
something out of kit last week he shut
me down I'm going to try and get
something out of you okay we're back in
60 seconds here on the show
if Westeros had wheels up and be like
the dragon of Westeros wheels up is the
spot that you need to go to right here
and right now for your aviation solution
in this crazy mixed-up world calls the
21st century guaranteed access to a
fleet of over 70 aircraft with as little
as 24 hours notice it's time for you to
up the way you fly with wheels up it's
the most intelligent private aviation
solution find out more at wheels up
comic all eight five five fly 8760
that's eight five five fly 8760 Game of
Thrones is back the man who plays Sam
Tarly Sam well Charlie's own John
Bradley here on the show you are from
Manchester correct that is yeah that is
your hometown
I'm Chester born and bred still live
this one and bred so does that make
sense that you're a man united
individual I'm a huge Man United fan
okay yeah so what'd you think of Wayne
Rooney going back to his boyhood team in
Everton what do you think about I think
it's sad but I think I think in terms of
if there was anywhere he was going to go
back to I think people have the most
amount respect to him the fact that he
has gone back to his boyhood team and
he's not taken a huge payday in China or
even the state and I mean he's gone back
to a club that means a lot to him and
he's clearly always been quite close to
his heart and you know it's gone a
little bit downhill for Wayne over the
last couple of seasons that United he
didn't play as much football last year
as he probably deserves to and I just
don't want people to forget just what a
wonderful player he was and I've been
watching kind of his gold compilations
recently he's good some of the most
memorable girls at old trafford ever
seen and he's always going to be a hero
he's always going to be a play that's
very close to the heart of the United
fans and he just wanted to end his
career a club that he loves playing
regular football and I think that you
know nobody's gonna nobody's going to
deny him the opportunity to play for
everyone again and there's going to be
no kind of bitterness or guilt or
recriminations if he ever comes back to
Old Trafford which he will I'm sure next
time he comes back to Ooty he's gonna
get a rousing reception from the iPhone
because he deserves it know when you
said he didn't take a big payday here in
the United States had a shot at David
Beckham but that I was at a Beckham
Bronson oh no definitely not
okay no no I want to started everything
up I wouldn't dare I wouldn't
have a go at DB he's another one of my
heroes but I just think that Wayne Wayne
is a kind of homebody
I think he's such is roots or so firmly
in Liverpool and his parents still there
and he belongs to that very kind of
close-knit community in Manchester's
only kind of 40 miles from Liverpool
anyway but I think that his heart would
always be there and so he I don't think
he could bring himself to play abroad or
even live abroad I think it's so kind of
entrenched in his fabric as a human
being he's never going to stray too far
and I think you know good look to him
and I appreciate using the word miles
instead of kilometers you didn't make me
do the math there oh no no no I really
appreciate now that you Americanized
your conversation right there I've
greatly appreciate well I'm from the I'm
from the old school miles because we
used to use miles we still do use miles
in the UK I don't know that yeah once
you get into continental Europe they
start to use columnar but okay I think
miles is miles did you see Manchester
United out here in Los Angeles
they're just here this week I didn't see
them play this weekend right but I
thought I went to watch them train
yesterday what do you mean I was invited
to watch the team train I couldn't
believe it look at that picture those
million and Joe saying my pal geo
Dempsey look at that look at that
greatest moment in my life that I think
who is who's the biggest game of Thrones
fan on the squad Paul Pogba Paul pod but
seemingly cannot get enough a game of
Thrones because he saw me across the
lobby of a hotel and freaked out how
often do you get that from Paul Pogba
no no not enough from Paul Fogg Webber
for yeah giving quite a lot especially
now when the shows on people is kind of
at the forefront of people's minds and
Road and there's something about also
stepping out of something they consider
to be a fantasy world and suddenly
seeing you in the real world there's
something really kind of exciting about
it like something that they can't
compute because they're used to seeing
you in the world of Game of Thrones and
they suddenly see you in a supermarket
and there's something that they can tell
you but when when you get your heroes
but Paul Pogba
who watches the show and he gives you
that kind of rush of feedback and he's
so positive and he's all over you and
he's hugging you and he's shaking your
hand and he keeps saying that you can't
believe he's met you it's moments like
that do you think the world's gone mad
Will's gone crazy well this show is as
popular a show
internationally obviously than any one
that I can possibly remember yeah what
is the strangest I'm with John Bradley
replaced Samwell Tarly of game of
thrones here on the show what's the
strangest fan theory of the show that's
the that somebody who is a fan of the
show has come up to you and say I think
this is going to happen well the
strangest one is that is that Lord Varys
is a mermaid or a merman or a merb
person right just because just because
he seems to get around the place
relatively quickly mmm compared to
everybody else like his movements are
completely inconsistent with the kind of
time logic of the show so why who came
up with the cut somebody came up to me
and said um erm yeah I'm not ever a
merman and because also also he's a
eunuch of course yes and you never see
him from the waist down and he's always
got these robes on and apparently
there's enough circumstantial evidence
for people to take it quite seriously I
mean I mean I don't very very flattering
that people are so invested in the show
that they come up with these theories
but when when it's the off season and
you hear people say stuff like that you
think we better get the show on quick
these people have find it all sorts of
ways to fill their time and it's not
healthy but let's get the show on and
get them watching it before and any any
of there's any more of this and you're
going to comic-con next what is that
like young men hungry Tommy become yeah
it's amazing what I find comic-con
obviously quite a moving experience
because all you get is people who quite
often I think feel kind of on the
fringes of society a little bit and feel
they leave a kind of alternative
lifestyle and sometimes they may not be
that confident in expressing their
passion for stuff like this but what you
getting comic-con is everybody the same
everybody that's passionate about this
stuff and it's just a very kind of
accepting place where everybody feels
safe and they feel that they can express
their true kind of passions and
interests people come in very obvious
way do people come dressed as you every
table duncan dosas made is because that
cost you in san diego weather
not going to be why I can barely cope
with it in Belfast but but they know you
do get you did get Game of Thrones
cosplay and stuff that there are a lot
of Daenerys because that costume lends
itself to sure that kind of heat but no
I mean if you if you want to go and get
some positive feedback for a show like
Game of Thrones and comic-con supposed
to do it's my fourth in a row and every
year I say you know I've kind of done it
now I've kind of had that experience but
over time the kind of your ego level
goes down and you think I could do with
a bit of a boost actually please that'd
be great so you John Bradley do you know
what happens in the end of this show no
do you have a theory as to what happens
at the end of this show I have my
theories what is it I can't tell you
come on oh if that's the kind of
questions you were asking kit last week
then I don't blame and for yeah I don't
thing is we why can't you give what you
is somebody else because somebody who's
in the show just to give you a theory as
to what you think what you don't have a
script for Season eight yet no no but
here's the visa thing about theories and
this is why I'm not going to give you my
theory today theories can go one of two
ways either I'm wrong in which case
there's documented evidence of me being
wrong think you can then cut back to in
two years time and say look how wrong
this guy was but what a fall I almost
start to do that I don't just I don't
trust anybody these days when I laugh
okay what's the order or I'm right and
I've ruined it and I mean but I've
ruined it for people by being right of
ruined it for myself by being right just
just you know you know you really can't
win with that stuff okay because they
because then the exact same piece of
footage is going to be on earth and John
Bradley spoilt the whole show two years
ago and everyone will accuse you of
having actually everybody will agree no
you say you do not know what is that
everybody would accuse whatever accuse
me of knowing all along which I don't
and it's are there going to be a lucky
guess
or I'm wrong and I don't want to be I
don't want to be a spoiler all wrong
when does season 8 start shooting season
is good start shooting to control the
end of this year I think there's no deaf
that day on that book it's going to be
weird to finish the show I mean it's a
show that I've been involved in for
seven years my entire career I don't
know what it's like to be an actor of
not being gay Malone so when it ends is
going to be bittersweet and everybody
knows what it's like in acting that
hardest part of acting for me is meeting
new crews all the time I'm meeting new
cast and finding your place within that
dynamic and and we Game of Thrones you
never had that because every year you go
back and work with the same group of
people who you know very well and trust
and we've developed a kind of rapport I
mean people talk about how big the cast
is and how spread out they are in the
fact that we don't see each other a lot
we don't sweep we you don't work with
most people but when you do come to
events like this or comic-con and you
see each other you'd really do feel like
you're part of this only so what can you
tell me about season seven I'm wrong
think I'm telling too many tales out of
school at last night's episode appeared
to be a table setter it was a table set
but okay I I think I think yeah it was a
good one do we get not up awesome yeah
this has nothing to do with anything
about the quality it's it's it's
wonderful yeah but it appeared to be a
table setter how fast do we get answers
one seven it's a pretty fast season okay
because we want to go seven episodes and
we've normally got ten episodes this
time we've got seven but your people
shouldn't think that they're going to
get seven episodes worth of drama you're
going to get a 10 episodes worth of
drama condensed into seven very rich and
very kind of fast-moving episodes I
think and the one thing you did spoil is
Varys is not a fish man that's what I
mean machine I have not we could sit
I've really killed that theory now live
I'm Rich Eisen that could be right and
that could be right yeah look how wrong
John Bradley was about the various
mermaid mmm conundrum okay by the way
we've had spoiler alert the two people
who have killed White Walkers on this
show we have yes that's right that
eighty gate that's the by the way that
we sit on my bar for our guests here on
the Richer you've got to have a
separately though it's like you've got
to have a separately because one of us
are always going to be on duty just in
case that's quite honest it's like the
way that you
don't give the pilot and the copilot on
the plane the same meal in case they
both get sick I think that's right I
might be an urban myth or a thing that's
right oh you know by the WAGs and I hope
they do do that and I hope valerian
still doesn't make it on the flight
either way but if if that sword makes it
on that flight and there have been there
are serious security questions
I create over there pretty thanks for
coming on thank you for having you bet
John Bradley is here
check out Game of Thrones if you already
have it my goodness HBO Sundays at 9:00
eastern time you're welcome back anytime
I'd love to come by good lovely thank
you sir Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you liked that
video be sure to download our apps don't
have any memory on your phone let's
start to delete some of those slo-mo
videos you have and you know which ones
I'm talking about